...prilude, imamo pravna pravila,
poslovna pravila
koja ima uleđenu funkcionisanu državu
i pomenuli smo dva osnovna
principa funkcionisanog država
koja su podlano čelo subordinacija
i koordinacija.
Subordinacija i odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti koju imamo državno
daje na različitom stepenu vlasti.
A kod koordinacije imamo isti
stepen vlasti i imamo saradnje.
To je ono što smo prošlog puta radili
i gde smo se ja da zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje.
Kada je reč o ljudima,
krenut ćemo sa ljudima
da vidimo koji to ljudi rade,
šta rade, kako rade i kakav je njihov
odnos prema državi kao organizaciji.
Državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini svo stanovništvo,
taj državni aparat čine samo neke
ljudi. Ti ljudi
koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim spužbenim ljude.
To su ljudi
koji rade u imenu za račun država.
E sad,
tim državnim službenim
licima se daju određene poslove.
Imate potređeno državno službeno lice,
dašte im da rade neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegovu radu.
Budim
da te o onšto jednostavnije objasnim,
ne da se držim ti definicije službenika,
nego najprostije je moguće
da vam objasnim.
Dakle, uzmeš neki posao, daže ga jednom
državnom suženom u lišću i kažeš evo ti,
napravo radi to, to je tvoja nadležnost.
Bukvalno tako.
E sada, postoje dve vrste nadležnosti u
principu i ova treća nekakva funkcionalna,
to je uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ću vam nju objasniti,
i prisutna je naravno u radu državnih
ordana, Ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudiju
koji je državno službeno lice,
jednog narodnog poslanika koji je državno
službeno lice, da li oni rade isti?